I can't believe he's so performative. He's like trying to pretend
like he doesn't know who these people are. Like he's not in one
like uh tweets about Pisco or Hotter or Hotter or Cold like trying
to instigate fights between us. Oh my god, he's such a loser.
Oh my god. Oh my god, he's such a
like a spineless cowardly He's such a Holy sh- He's so fragile.
>> Apparently the Live and Learn clips with Tim Miller
are hitting the timeline.
People laughing at Hutch being a total about his beliefs on Hasan.
That Tim Miller comes in and says, "Hey, I I actually think it's
a huge mistake to attack Hasan." And Hutch just closes his
Really says nothing. Really just mans down completely.
Totally mans down. Very funny. Lots people posting this clip,
reacting to this clip, laughing at this clip. Wait, did Hasan
react to this clip today? I feel like I saw him looking at this
clip for some reason.
>> Someone hit us with that reaction.
>> Of course in our spaces in recent kind of weeks. Some
of it has related to Hasan, but it's more been about like a bigger
conversation about the future of the Democratic Party. You're
obviously like a Republican defector and so I'm curious to know
what you think should be the playbook for Democrats in the short
term to sort of maximize electoral wins and also like what you
personally want to see and do those things overlap? >> Yeah,
can I just say one of on just Hasan briefly? Uh what I I engaged
in that discourse very early,
uh which in retrospect was maybe a mistake cuz I who the hell
the hell did I know that it's all everybody want to talk about
for weeks. But one of the points I made when I first engaged
with that is that like the establishment Republicans or excuse
me, the establishment Democrats [laughter] I'm talking about
a Freudian slip. The establishment Democrats who are going after
him were like st- stepping on a big rake. Like this is this is
a massive self-own. Like putting out a memo that's like people
shouldn't talk to Hasan is going to absolutely backfire. >> Hold
on. I'm I'm waiting a little too Hold on. We need to get the
Hutch view, okay? We need the Hutch view. >> But one of
the points I made when I first engaged with it is that like the
establishment Republicans or excuse me, the establishment Democrats
and talk about a Freudian slip. The establishment Democrats who
are going after him were like st- stepping on a big rake. Like
this was this was a massive self-own. Like putting out a memo
that's like people shouldn't talk to Hasan is going to absolutely
backfire on them and you know, the the base or like the active
Democratic voter is not base or like the >> This guy's
tweaking all the time. It's just so funny, man. >> active
Democratic voter is not does not want that and you know, there's
some category of people that do, but if anything will end up
empowering him more to like as an anti-establishment figure who's
fighting them cuz that's what people are looking for right now.
Look at Gran Plottner and Janet Mills and and that's exactly
what's happening. >> Dude, look at this guy's eyes go.
>> what people are looking for right now. Look at Gran
Plottner and Janet Mills and and that's exactly what's happening
and it was really dumb of the third party to do it. This is a
strategic >> Dude, what the hell is happening with this
guy?
>> Um my my thinking um and I feel like I I have good credibility.
>> on. We've got the Hasan reaction. I'll pull up the Hasan
react to this. I'm interested in that. I want to see what Hasan
has to say. Let me see here. Hasan, let's check this out. >> I
like that they're at least honest. This is right before the election
though, so they probably thought that this was going to secure
the W, which is why they were very confident and did not shy
away from saying that like Kamala is listening to us, right?
[snorts]
I was on the other side going, "Kamala is listening to them.
She shouldn't." And we now know which side was correct,
I will at least readily admit Tim Miller on the other hand is
a little bit more
Okay? Tim Miller on the other hand is at least like a demon of
the internet, so he he he sees the way the winds are blowing,
So, I guess he went on this podcast with
Hodge
Pisco,
the Soy Pill, who I've I don't think I've ever seen until this
day. I've only seen like the the drawn image of him. And uh this
is like a like a liberal
>> I think that's just Hasan saying he's watched some of
Soy Pill's videos. He's unaware of the the moniker yet of Tequila
Sunrise, okay? Well, he's got to discover that on his own. You
can't You can't force that on people. >> and forth, right?
This is their This is like the the prime
liberal Hasan headquarters. Pisco is not a Hasan guy. I think
Soy Pill might be. I don't know. But as you guys know, Hutch
has uh famously said
uh Hutch has famously said he would rather vote for Jeffrey Epstein
instead [laughter] of me.
Did Hutch say Hitler, too? Or was that just yesterday? I can't
remember. One of them Destiny definitely said he'd vote for Hitler
over Hasan, right? >> we've got a ton of discourse in our
spaces in recent >> So, this is new. This is the Tim Miller
thinking about like the Hasan discourse and what that has created
recently, I assume. >> Some of it has related to Hasan,
but it's more been about like a bigger conversation about the
future of the Democratic Party. You're obviously like a Republican
defector, and so I'm curious to know what you think should be
the playbook for Democrats in the short term to sort of maximize
electoral wins, and also like what you personally want to see,
and do those things overlap? >> Yeah, can I just say one
of the on Hasan briefly? When I engaged in that discourse very
early,
which in retrospect was maybe a mistake cuz I How the hell did
I know that it's all everybody want to talk about for weeks?
But one of the points I made when I first engaged with it is
that like the establishment Republicans or excuse me, the establishment
Democrats >> I'm talking about a Freudian slip. The establishment
Democrats who were going after him were like stepping on a big
rake. Like this is this is a massive self-own. Like putting out
a memo that's like people shouldn't talk to Hasan is going to
absolutely backfire on them. And you know, the the base like
the active Democratic voter is not does not want that and you
know there's some category of people that do but if anything
it will end up >> Dude, Hasan is missing out, okay? He's
not even watching Hutch. That's like the best part of watching
Hutch at any point in time is just watching him totally like
his eyes dart around the room.
So I feel somehow what again showing up for the stream somehow
this guy
This guy must not have air conditioning his place. I swear to
god.
Oh wait, no sorry this No, this isn't just a recent stream again.
>> empowering him more to like there's an empty establishment
figure who's fighting them cuz that's what people are looking
for right now. Uh look at Janet Mills and uh and that's exactly
what's happened and it was really dumb of the third way to do
it just as a strategic matter. Um my
It was and that's precisely the reason why I welcomed it. I said
they're united in their hatred of me and I welcome their hatred.
FDR.
Tim Miller at least understood that. He also understood that
one of the key problems with the National Democratic Party that
led to their demise against the incompetent tyrannical fascist
Donald Trump the second time around was their inability to address
the popular sentiment that was growing at the time that was the
just sentiment that was the moral sentiment that was the moral
center of the party or at least the base of support within the
party and now the entire nation
which was Israel, okay? Holding Israel >> Do you feel like
have you been following this enough clearly to have an opinion
on whether or not it was Israel that if Kamala flips on Israel
in some tangible way she gets more votes?
I still don't know if I believe that.
I've been following it enough for that. Um I would assume it's
either that or like the populist angle though.
>> The the populist angle that not being like the the neocon
type. I feel like the optics of that are quite bad. Like leaning
into more than neocon policies. Leaning out of basically you
lean out of the thing that differentiates you. You start like
muddying yourself and and not being differentiated on I guess
the military and even though I don't necessarily think any of
that rhetoric is bad, but I do think that at that point in time
people weren't like woke enough on Israel quite yet where if
you if you made like a major stand, let's say you basically said
if Israel can't stop committing war crimes or we have some evidence
of this and if I find evidence of war crimes I'm going to stop
aid to I think there's a chance that that causes like a major
funding
gap that you like a lot of people switch parties essentially.
Did that mean MSM would have been 24/7 Israel Israel Israel?
Maybe, but I think conventional wisdom probably pushes you away
from it. I'm not sure which way it would have I feel like it
probably wouldn't have been a good decision to make it like a
Maybe if you just say if I find out Israel's committing war crimes,
I would consider cutting off aid. I think that's what Ogorboy
said would be his line. If she did that, maybe that is enough
where it's like she can't really be pilloried for it, but it
is like a concession of kind or of a kind.
Maybe maybe that would be enough. >> Yeah, I would just
assume that Israel Israel law being like, you know, a left populist,
you know, basic basically I would assume it says that you know,
the Mamdani style is like what's popular right now is roughly
what I would assume the base want to say.
all the prescriptions taken away from it to be >> Yeah,
how much Like how much different do you think Kamala Harris is?
Like to me I think not committing to Lina Khan was like the big
one for me where a lot of people but I I actually know who Lina
Khan is and I'm guessing most people don't. So I wonder what
rhetoric she did that would make people think she wasn't sort
of more economically populist. Cuz it felt like she did say it.
It's just like nobody believed it almost. Like she was saying
oh we're going to make it better for working class families,
we're going to do no tax on tips. She took that from Trump. We're
going to do like all these programs to make it better for people
with less money. I feel like she said it. I just feel like people
didn't believe it or something. I don't know. I don't know what
kind of trap she was in. >> it just wasn't some big earth-shattering
policy, you know, that you if you're going to do the whole populist
thing, you have to have something that's actually going to sort
of upend system a little bit. Yeah, you make life a rule or something
like that. It just didn't have anything.
>> Yeah, nothing.
That That might be a better way to talk about it is like give
the media something they have to give you free media on. Like
something that's enough of a shake-up that you you force people
to cover it. >> She just never did that. She was like
>> the cut-through. It's about like, you know, there's
something there.
>> Yeah, didn't even distance from Biden, right? Like refused
to say that like oh I you know, I didn't really do much in this
presidency or something to distance herself. Yeah.
>> The refusal
to to recognize that was what led to their their refusal to recognize
is that is what led to their
What led to the electoral defeat.
Now, Tim has also recognized that I have credibility in this
space. You know, I never shied away from offering my perspective.
I got endlessly yelled at for it in many instances by you know,
people that are either on this panel or people that you know,
agree
with people on this panel, right? But the reality was
I was correct.
And therefore now
I have that legitimacy
in this space because I've been an advocate in this space for
many many >> I thought Hassan would have some more commentary
than this and just like agreeing with Tim and basically saying
the same thing Tim said about him. I agree with that. I just
thought maybe he would laugh cuz I think it's super funny that
Hutch just refused to say anything. Like Hutch Tim Miller basically
said Hutch is up for the past like 6 months and Hutch was just
quiet. Just had nothing. Nothing at all. Nothing was going on.
>> Those very same Democrats do not have that legitimacy.
They do not have that credibility in this space. So, for them
to like consistently attack me, for them to consistently turn
around and attack me and say, "Oh, Hasan is wrong. Hasan is wrong."
Uh and uh you shouldn't listen to him. He's a dangerous radical.
Most people don't look at that and go, "Okay, I guess Hasan is
wrong. We're going to move on. We're going to find a different
anti-Israel voice." Most people look at that and go, "Oh, here
they go again being pro-Israel."
And in many respects, that is the case. Israel first is the determining
uh reason for why they consider to me uh they consider me to
be a dangerous
Like the the Sarah Longwells of the world or all these other
people that have written endless articles are worried about the
Democratic Party uh uh having to take a close
>> The weird thing is that I don't know how you do this
necessarily, but there's no way to like crystallize that they
totally that that was their problem and they missed on it completely.
And to like reference back to it. Cuz you can pull up the Third
Way article, but now everybody's just like, "Actually, it's all
about him being a liberal." Like they've switched totally away
from the anti-Semitism thing.
And you can keep reminding people, but it's like
it's funny how fast the GOP shift when people miss like that.
Like they just shift completely and there's it feels like it's
very difficult to pin them down and say, "Oh, so you admit that
this was wrong. You don't You don't want to make this criticism
anymore."
It is a lot of work. >> Look at what the people are demanding,
what the base is demanding, what uh what the role I play in being
a megaphone for this base. Okay? So, it doesn't work. >> My
thinking um
>> Uh the funny thing is is this is Tim Miller's position
precisely. And I'm guessing for right like this Destiny reaction.
I'm guessing Destiny's going to be very upset about whatever
Hasan said here, right? But he's actually just repeating what
Tim Miller said. And then Destiny after Tim Miller said that,
Destiny had a conversation with Tim Miller. I wonder how much
Destiny pushed back in that situation, cuz I want to say that
Destiny's reaction to Tim Miller in that situation was something
like, "Oh yeah, I totally agree. It's like crazy to call Hasan
an anti-Semite." Am I making that up? I'm pretty sure that was
the
So how did How did Destiny say that to Tim Miller directly? And
then when Hasan says, when he echoes what Tim Miller had already
said, that he's an authority on this one issue, that he resonates
with voters on this one issue, and attacking him on it is a mistake.
I I don't know how if you didn't hit Tim Miller on it, how you
going to hit >> I mean, I feel like I I have good credibility
on this cuz like when I'm about to suggest the Democrats do,
it goes against like what my personal political preference would
be. You know, if I could wave a magic wand to make somebody president,
I would want like Jared Polis or somebody like that who has no
no
Jared Polis is God damn, you have a magic wand, you're going
to put Jared Polis in there? Jesus Christ. >> viability
as a national figure. Um but I think that
the Democrats need to put forth a a >> He said I want a
Redditor president. God >> Cuz we're doing this in a 2028
context, but even at statewide candidates and federal level,
uh who has some distance from the
trial bridge. Um and like they need some distance from >> Jared
Polis is the governor of Colorado. I know nothing about this
guy. No, literally nothing about him at all. >> And it
needs to be like comprehensible and understandable to people,
to dum-dums, like what the difference is. And I think probably
it is uh a little bit more economic populism. What that exactly
looks like, I think is up to the person, but mostly it is that
they need to offer a critique of the Democratic Party establishment
for being too cozy with corporate interests and saying that they're
going to fight it at some level. Some of the Some of those proposals
will be very stupid, but like there's some that are that are
good, and and I think that the framing is more important than
the actual thought. >> I liked [clears throat] that. There
>> Oh, I actually missed that. Tim Miller basically said
the exact same things I've been saying that Hutch freaked the
[__] out about. I hope Hutch pushes back on that
one, right?
Is Hutch just Hutch just only has smoke for people who are insulting
to him, I guess. That he doesn't care what you say, he doesn't
care about your politics. If you're nice to him, he's got no
smoke for you at all. He doesn't even disagree with you. He's
like, "Oh, that's a really great point." You're mean to him,
you say something mean, you laugh at the stupid faces he makes,
oh my god. You're like not even a You're not even make your recommendation.
You're not even a real political person. >> Tim has finally
arrived at just fake it. Tim has arrived at just like just be
>> Oh, yeah. The funny thing is for him, Tim is one to
one with me cuz I the everything I've been saying on immigration,
he basically echoed it, too. Which I felt bad cuz I'm he's not
saying that's the policy he likes, by the way. He's saying this
is what leftist should do. So, I just think it's funny that I
have the same read on that. That this is like more what lefties
should be trying to push towards. >> Fake being a populist,
please. Like just lie and say you're going to do this because
it's very clear that that's what the public wants.
It's very clear where the public appetite is right now. And it's
true, and they definitely see it. And I will use as a jump off
point to talk about Liz Smith,
um who is working
All right, do we do this? Oh, Mr. Mr. Mouton's here, too, for
his opinion as well. Very cool. We all just threw up watching
you back. We all just threw up >> Yeah, I know who's got
control of THE WEATHER, THOUGH. WOAH.
is a little
>> a little bit more responsive. >> less offensive
to the eye, I guess. >> Okay. Tim Miller, on the other
hand, is at least like a demon of the internet. So, he he he
sees the way the winds are blowing.
So, I guess he went on this podcast with
Hutch,
Pisco,
the soy pill. >> He's so performative.
I can't believe he's so performative. He's like trying to pretend
like he doesn't know who these people are. Like he's not in one
like uh tweets about Pisco or Hutch or Soy Boy like trying to
instigate fights between us. Oh my god, he's such a loser. Oh
my god.
>> Who I've I I don't think I've ever seen until this day.
I've only seen like the >> Oh my god, he's such a
like a spineless cowardly He's such a Holy sh He's so fragile.
>> Is this so funny cuz Hasan is openly saying he knows
all of these people?
Right? Like that's That's how bad it is. Hasan's openly saying
he knows all of these people and he he paused here a little too
early.
Cuz he does actually know who Soy Boy Pill is. >> the drawn
image of him And uh this is like a like a liberal >> He's
roll past that. >> and forth, right? This is [laughter]
the
>> He All he says is, "I know Soy Boy Pill is the the drawn
guy. I know that guy. I've never seen him before."
So he basically admits he knows all of these people. He says
he knows all of these people. And then he's like, "Why is he
pretending that he doesn't know any of these people?" >> Uh
this is like the the prime
liberal Hasan headquarters. Pisco is not a Hasan guy.
>> I think Soy Boy Pill might be. I don't know. But as
you guys know, Hutch is there. This is like the the prime >> Hold
on. >> liberal Hasan headquarters. Pisco is not a Hasan
guy. I think Soy Boy Pill might >> So he knows Pisco's
position on Hasan, but he had to read it or like it's a Hutch,
um Pisco,
um the Soy Boy Like this is the primary hate Hasan podcast, by
the way. Pisco's cool with us though. It's like How do you even
know this and you but you're like faking? Like I don't know who
these people are. Oh my god.
>> Yeah, Hasan's Hasan's the performative one, for sure.
Hasan Hasan's definitely the performative one here. Yep.
>> I don't know. But as you guys know, Hutch is >> Hasan
does do that. In different cases, yeah. He's not doing that in
this case. He knows exactly who Hutch and Pisco are. He's not
even remotely like attempting to pretend that he doesn't know
who Pisco is or
Hutch has famously said he would rather vote for Jeffrey Epstein
>> Oh my god. >> instead of me. Yeah, so we've we've
got a ton of discourse in our spaces >> politics. So this
is new. This is the Tim Miller thinking about like the Hasan
discourse and what that has created
I assume. >> weak. Some of it has related to Hasan, but
it's more been about like a bigger conversation about the future
of the Democratic Party. You're obviously like a Republican defector,
and so I'm curious to know what you think should be the playbook
for Democrats in the short term to sort of maximize electoral
wins, and also like what you personally want to see, and do those
things overlap? >> Yeah, can I just say one of the on just
Hasan briefly? I I I engaged in that discourse very
which in retrospect was maybe a mistake cuz I who the hell did
I know that it's all everybody want to talk about for weeks.
But one of the points I made when I first engaged with it is
that like the establishment Republicans or excuse me, the establishment
Democrats >> I talk about a Freudian slip. The establishment
Democrats who are going after him were like st- stepping on a
big rake. Like this was this was a massive self-own, like putting
out a memo that's like people >> Is him trying to drive
a wedge? Yes, of course. He has to watch it. He's got to support
the pro-Hasan element. It's
I hate Hasan with all my which is watch
>> Dude, this guy is so
This guy is like a a rat on a sinking ship. He's so paranoid
of everything that happens. I don't even think Hasan even comment.
Does Hasan comment on Pisco to say he supports him? He just says,
"Oh, this Pisco, he's not a Hasan guy." But this is like Hasan
>> single accusation that like just to go in that crowd
and everybody have always made towards me.
>> Speaking of paranoid. >> I guess Hasan has echoed
a lot of these, too. And then know that that's their plan. That's
what they do, right? So the accusation was always that I was
trying to isolate people and reward people for being loyalists
and punish people for being dissenters and all this. This is
what they're doing. So, the goal for Hasan watching this is to
watch this, support um Pisco 100% and I guess Tim Miller, if
he was told uh Hasan absolutely was informed beforehand uh what
this clip was. Oh yeah, it's on it's not even the podcast, it's
on that Queen in Yellow's Twitter. So, he knows this is a Hasan
friendly Twitter account. Um and so, it's to provide critical
support for his allies and then to tear down or attack the people
that he perceives to be against him. Yeah. >> Do you think
Hasan would watch the source material? >> No, never. He
doesn't do that. >> Yeah, I don't know if he ever does
That's like unless I'm missing something, completely
>> It sounds when Democrats were going after him were like
stepping on a big rake. Like this is this is a massive self-own.
Like putting out a memo that's like people shouldn't talk to
Hasan is going to absolutely backfire on them and uh you know
>> You know what? Des- Destiny's actually right. It's wrong.
It's totally wrong when people are talking about you on a podcast
on your side of the political spectrum. It's actually wrong and
obsessive and weird and gross to react to those things. That's
actually really wrong. If you react to those things, that's wrong.
You shouldn't do that, ever. Just reacting to content where people
are talking about you? Act- yeah, this is this is a nefarious
action. Totally nefarious action. When Destiny goes and reacts
to content Pisco's doing on the DNC and calls him a communist
repeatedly, not not trying to punish, not being a nothing like
that, okay? When Hasan comments on basically just people talking
about him, that's bad. That's abusive, okay? It's driving away
>> the active kind of democratic voter is not does not
want that and you know, there's some category of people that
do, but if anything will end up empowering him more to like as
an anti-establishment figure who's fighting them cuz that's what
people are looking for right now. Uh look at Grand Platter and
Janet Mills and uh and that's exactly what's happened and it
was really dumb of the third way to do it as a strategic matter.
Um my
It was and that's precisely the reason why I welcomed it. I said
they're united in their hatred of me and I welcome their hatred.
>> He didn't welcome it. He was crying like a little baby
when people would attack him. Why you guys focus on me? You guys
need to be focused on the Republicans. Don't attack me. YOU GUYS
NEED TO ATTACK the Republicans. That's cute, but okay. >> Good.
FDR.
Tim Miller at least under- It was. And that's precisely the reason
why I welcomed it. I said they're united in their hatred of me
and I welcome their hatred. FDR.
Tim Miller at least understood that. He also understood that
one of the key problems with the National Democratic
>> He He's just seething when this guy talks. I love it.
I love it. Hasan just says anything and he's like seething
>> to their demise against the incompetent tyrannical fascist
Donald Trump the >> Lost Okay. Lost an election, won election,
lost an election. Demise of Democratic Party, by the way. >> second
time around was their inability to address
>> I I think he's talking about in the >> the popular
sentiment that was growing at the time that was the just sentiment,
that was the moral sentiment, that was the moral center of the
party or at >> Fantastic. Did you guys miss that addition
from from Mr. Booten here? Love this guy's politics. Really coming
to his own over here. Fantastic commentator, this guy. >> of
support within the party and now the entire nation
which was Israel, okay? Holding Israel accountable, stopping
Israel's genocide.
>> The refusal
to to recognize that was what led to their their refusal to recognize
is that is what led to the electoral defeat.
>> what led to the electoral defeat.
>> Another fantastic point from Mr. Booten. That's a great
That's a great response. I think people are really upset that
America's been abetting a genocide. Uh This is the guy who said
Crimea river. A Russian river.
I Okay. Is that
Do you think that affected the election or No? Okay. Keep going.
>> Tim has also recognized that I have credibility in the
space. You know, I never shied away from offering my perspective.
I got endlessly yelled at for it in many instances by you know,
people that are either on this panel or people that you know,
agree
>> with people on this panel. >> He's talking about
the I'm people by the way, but okay. >> That's you?
>> But the reality was
I was correct.
And therefore now
I have that legitimacy
in the space because I've been an advocate in this space for
many, many years. Those very same Democrats do not have that
legitimacy. They do not have that credibility in this space.
So for them to like consistently attack me, for them to consistently
turn around and attack me and say oh Hasan is wrong, Hasan is
wrong
and you shouldn't listen to him. He's a dangerous radical.
Most people don't look at that and go okay, I guess Hasan is
wrong. We're going to move on. We're going to find a different
anti-Israel voice. Most people look at that and go oh here they
go again being pro-Israel. >> Just most people don't know
who Hasan is even in the Democratic Party. That's most people's
perspectives, but
>> And in many respects that is the case. Israel first
is the determining >> Oh my god. >> reason for why
they consider to me they consider me to be a dangerous radical.
>> Then true. >> Okay. Israel first.
>> Like the the Sarah Longwells of
>> Is he martyring himself? Just another fantastic comment
that is actually like a response to the conversation in some
way. This guy is definitely adding a lot to the stream over here.
Okay, is he martyring? Is he martyring himself? >> the
world [snorts] or all these other people that have written endless
>> Is this reality? Well, unfortunately Destiny totally
knelt to Tim Miller on this reality missy, so like basically
he knows he can't really respond or be angry about this or disagree.
I think he's just waiting hoping that Hasan will say some talk
some [__] about Hutch or Soy Pill or big up Pisco
or something so that he can make a point, but I guess maybe he
just
Yeah, that's all I could think of cuz obviously he can't disagree
on any of the actual material here, right?
>> Endless articles. worried about the Democratic Party
uh having to take a close look at what the people are demanding,
what the base is demanding, what uh what the role I play in being
a megaphone for this base, okay?
>> So, it doesn't work. >> My thinking and I feel
like I I have good credibility on this cuz like what I'm about
to suggest the Democrats do goes against like what my personal
political preference would be. You know, if I could wave a magic
wand to make somebody president, I would want like Jared Polis
or somebody like that who has no no
>> Jared Polis, god damn, you have a magic wand, you can
put Jared Polis in there?
Jesus Christ. >> his viability as a national figure. Um
but I think that uh the Democrats need to put forth a candidate
>> He said I want a redditor president. God >> things
in 2028 contacts, but even at the state level candidates and
federal level uh who has some distance from the
Um and like they need some distance from them and it needs to
be like comprehensible and understandable to people, to dum-dums
like what the difference is. And I think probably it is uh a
little bit more economic populism. What that exactly looks like
I think is up to the person, but mostly it is that they need
to offer a critique of the Democratic Party establishment for
being too cozy with corporate interests and saying that they're
going to fight it at some level. Some of the some of these proposals
will be very stupid, but like there's some that are that are
good and and I think that the framing is more important than
the actual I like that there Tim has finally arrived at just
fake it.
Tim has arrived at just like just fake being a populist, please.
Like just lie and say you're going to do this because it's very
clear that that's what the public wants. It's very clear where
the public appetite is right now. And it's true and they definitely
see it. I don't think this is what Tim is saying. I think Tim
is saying either I think he's saying it doesn't matter like you
need to do it somehow. I think he's saying it doesn't matter
if you're sincere about it or not or like what you really think
there. I don't think he's saying just lie but don't do it. >> And
I will uh this as a jump-off point to talk about Liz Smith, um
who is working with the Mallory McMorrow campaign uh against
Abdul El-Sayed.
What she's >> So, remember, this was apparently in Destiny's
conspiratorial brain, this was apparently for Hasan to [__]
on Hutch and Soy Pill, which I [__] on Hutch plenty
there, but apparently it's for Hasan to [__] on Hutch
and Soy Pill and and boost Pisco and Tim Miller. And all Hasan
did was talk about himself.
Realistically, wasn't that always the most predictable outcome?
That Hasan was just going to talk about himself.
Could we just Could we just be real? Of course that was what
Hasan was going to do. Come on, man. Come on. Of course that's
what he was going to do. >> He's been doing. The establishment
of the Democratic Party is so unbelievably unpopular that Mallory
McMorrow privately went to Chuck Schumer and had a closed-door
meeting. We don't know what that conversation looked like, but
Mallory McMorrow has been openly saying Chuck Schumer has to
go. He has to be replaced. And yet Chuck Schumer, recognizing
that Haley Stevens, the other Apex stooge in this race, has no
real viability and no real popularity. >> Hey. Hey. Hey.
Hey.
Stevens is not an Apex stooge. She's a J Street stooge, okay?
Come on. Watch it,
You're getting your advocacy, your Israeli or advocacy groups
mixed up. What the hell? >> lent support to Mallory McMorrow.
And that's part of
>> American advocacy groups are
not a monolith, Hasan. And it's disgusting that you would suggest
that. >> The reason why I think you're seeing a lot more
Democratic senators and and uh the the DSC uh the DC the DSCC
uh the the funding arm of the uh Democratic uh Senate
work alongside Mallory McMorrow now. Well, Mallory McMorrow and
Liz Smith by the the the media uh demon behind Mallory McMorrow's
campaign
>> Okay, but unironically
But unironically, J Street is like a is just going to take over
for AIPAC because of the AIPAC the bad AIPAC press. J Street's
not really going to lead to meaningful change. It's not like
anywhere near enough. They have some They have a better like
advocacy platform, but it's not going to lead to any tangible
change. But, it's a you know, it's like a little better, I guess.
You can acknowledge that and say it's basically still trying
to maintain status quo.
But, whatever. In any case, hold on, what else was he going to
look at? Is uh yeah, Destiny's just not saying anything. Destiny
basically made a prediction on how this was going to go. He thought
this was the
the J-Stock Hasan cabal was so set by him, all right? That's
what he thought it was going to be, but then it was just Hasan
talking about himself and saying accurate things about himself.
So, Destiny couldn't even really get that angry. So, he basically
just watched Hasan talk about himself and how much he loves himself
for like 15 minutes. Pretty cool stuff. >> basically lie
about Abdullah Sayid's position. I don't know why they're doing
a full court press on this, cuz as I said here, this is the funniest
thing to lie about. But, Lismith says, "Breaking political reports
that neither Haley for Michigan, Haley Stevens, nor Abdullah
Sayid will join Mallory McMorrow in opposing Schumer for leader."
Even more progressive candidates like El-Sayed are struggling
with how to answer the Schumer question last April as McMorrow
insisted Democrats pick a leader besides Schumer. El-Sayed said,
"Anybody who tells you that they're going to unilaterally oppose
one potential candidate without knowing who the alternative is
is either un-nuanced or unsophisticated. So, I want to know who's
available, who's actively seeking the leadership. I'll make a
decision from there." In recent days, El-Sayed has floated Senator
Chris Van Hollen of Maryland as a potential leader. So, has El-Sayed's
thinking evolved since last year, or does he stand by saying
Schumer doesn't necessarily need to go? A spokesperson wouldn't
quite say. "Abdullah deeply believes that Washington should let
Michigan voters decide on this primary rather than putting their
thumb on the scale. It's not about who Schumer opposes. It's
about who Schumer opposes." Now, the reason why they said that
is because Chuck Schumer opposes Abdullah Sayid.
El-Sayed has also said he wants Van
He wants Chuck Schumer replaced with Van Hollen. So, he's already
made his his position be very well known. Chuck Schumer, on the
other hand, has lent a lot of support to uh Haley Stevens in
the beginning and then has said he would be comfortable, quietly
though, because The best part about this is that
Destiny and Mouton, they don't even They probably are vaguely
aware of the names at best. They're not really political analysts
in any way. They're barely following, right? So, they would I'm
sure they would like to disagree with Hasan on any of this, but
they don't actually know the reality of the situation, so they
can't really speak. >> on public is quietly has revealed
uh this is also reported in Politico that he'd be fine with Mallory
McMorrow as >> Cool. Cool cool cool cool cool.